unlocking your house storing your work
badge and scanning into your hotel room
are just some of the new things coming
to apple products this fall
the new ios 15 will also allow something
people
have been waiting for for a long time
and that is digital ids
you'll just scan your driver's license
or state id in participating u.s
states it's that easy your id
information
is now in wallet encrypted and safely
stored in the secure element
the same hardware technology that makes
apple pay
private and secure now even though this
is launching in the fall the dmv tells
us nevada could see digital ids
within the next two to four years so
we're not going to be right there at the
front of the line but
it's eventually coming i like the
scanning into the hotel room because
i've been in that situation a few times
you're at the hotel pool go
up to the room oh i didn't the key was
the key
right you have the key that doesn't seem
to work
you just keep trying it i like that
phone option it's coming